can I just point out one flaw in the
poll and this is not a knock on
Rasmussen but don't you have to ask beer
drinkers because this is asking adults
it's a thousand adults and that's the
problem we always have with these
political polls that come out when they
try to push people one way or another
they say we pulled a thousand adults
about Trump well adults aren't
registered voters and registered voters
aren't likely voters and it's not the
best sampling it's not no but I disagree
uh I don't drink but I'm a beer buyer we
we typically would have a beer stocked
here we haven't done a little bit but we
would go out to different breweries in
the area and we'd pick up cases of beer
because we have guests and we have
people humans like beer you know so I
think it's fine you know just because
and think about think of this way too
let's say I don't know what percentage
of people don't drink beer at all right
they're going to go out with their
friends still and they're gonna be like
hey don't buy that they're going to
support the boycott well some of us
don't drink light beer at all
hahaha